so I'm Callum lo I'm Director at
Robertson Sumner recruitment we're tech
sales and technical recruitment agency
about twenty one twenty one staff
economy
start the personal branding program
because I for one and sort of started to
my own personal brand and getting a lot
from it and I thought there was a lot of
people within our business who could who
could generate as much inbound sort of
activity and inbound interest into
interrupts and services clients and
candidates and to be honest with me
saying it myself it was it was just the
same voice just saying exactly the same
thing as to I was the same person
talking about their number but also
talking about this new personal branding
thing and it wasn't quite going in it
wasn't actually sort of working quite as
well as I'd made it work
a huge amount it's only been six weeks
since since we started but there's been
a huge amount of success already
everyone's profile views has gone up a
decent percentage I think well number
one people have been posting so there's
been a consistent amount of posts going
out from from individuals within within
the Roberts a summer business which is
great the engagement has been through
the roof
we've been people having people come up
to us knowing more much more about both
our business but also the individuals
out within our business and not only
that the engagements great but it's also
great when it turns into cash and this
there's been a whole host of candidates
registered new jobs bought bought into
the business but also placements made
and it's only been six weeks so a huge
amount of positive stuff just from just
from a short period of time
I think he comes great I think it's nice
having a fresh voice talk about this
sort of this sort of thing I think
throughout the whole processes this has
been a pretty engaging process for
everyone involved from the first
workshop people assume there's not much
to talk about but there's as soon as he
Shan comes in and talk talks through
different ideas and actually engages
people people are thinking the ideas
themselves it's not huge I'm actually
saying Oh have you thought about talking
about this it's people people coming up
with the ideas themselves and that's
through patience sort of waving engaging
with with people throughout the process
it's sort of people are handheld so
actually they know exactly what they
should be posting they get regular
feedback as to actually yeah that's a
good idea that's maybe not such a good
idea and to be honest it's just it's
worked wonders for us and I'd recommend
it to any recruitment business out there
I think recruitments changing quite a
lot in the way that the way that people
are working I think a lot of it needs to
be inbound I think there needs to be a
social media and LinkedIn especially is
one of the biggest tools in recruitment
so you're not taking advantage and
you're not the top of everyone's
newsfeed as a recruiter within within
the recruitment market 2019 2020 I think
you're losing so if this gives everyone
a great opportunity to do that and not
from just a director's perspective or a
business leaders perspective actually
everyone throughout the business should
be creating their own personal brand